bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord quelle
est la situation en guyane puisque on
s'inquiète face aux variants brésilien
bonsoir
écoutez en guyenne les choses sont on
évolue lentement mais nous essayons en
tout cas des rassurer nos patients les
variants brésilien est bien présent et
d'ailleurs devient majoritaire par
rapport au roi sur les cas de
contamination ici en guyane mais on peut
dire que la situation est encore
contrôlable il faut faire de la
pédagogie inciter les gens à se faire
vacciner est en tout cas se faire
dépister
pour l'instant ce n'est pas encore
catastrophique et comment vous jugez les
mesures qui ont été prises couvre feu
renforcé à des renforts qui viennent de
la métropole notamment pour vacciner
oui oui alors c'est à dire que c'est un
plan blanc qu'on connaît déjà en guyane
lors de la grosse vague la première
vague on a eu des renforts venant de
l'hexagone et les deux préfet a pris des
dispositions qui sont déjà connus c'est
à dire que y aura un couvre-feu à partir
du samedi 17 des 19 heures jusqu'au
lundi à 5 heures du matin c'est des
mesures qui ont déjà été prises par le
passé qu'ils ont montré une certaine
efficacité
c'est qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il faut
se rappeler de la frontière qui existe
entre la guyane et le brésil c'est une
frontière longue difficile à contrôler
assez poreuse quand même et on a des
gens qui viennent de part et d'autre qui
peuvent aggraver la situation locale qui
est déjà fragile mais à l'heure actuelle
nous notre travail a tant que médecin
c'est d'essayer dé rassurer nos patients
les dépister au maximum les inciter à se
faire vacciner
les mesures du week-end du confinement
et sont des mesures nécessaires qui ont
déjà produit leurs effets des toutes les
façons la semaine on est déjà sous un
couvre-feu à partir de 19 heures
jusqu'au lendemain matin 5h alors
justement là vous parliez du brésil
les frontières sont fermées avec le
brésil 1 concerne en tout cas la halle
la métropole ce n'est pas le cas avec la
guyane le gouvernement qui demande quand
même aux voyageurs en provenance de
vienne d'effectuer un test antigénique
en plus du test pc à négatif et d'être
aussi avec le motif impérieux
obligatoire pour voyager donc qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ces mesures est ce
qui a créé un risque réel le risque est
toujours réelle c'est un risque qu'on
peut pas mesurer de manière objective c
des risques d c'est un risque supposé
des toutes les façons ces mesures sont
déjà en vigueur depuis plusieurs mois
pour aller pour se rendre à l'hexagone
tout voyageur guyane et avait déjà
besoin d'un motif impérieux avait déjà
besoin d'un test psrc qui vient d'être
rajoutée
c'est un peu un test antigénique
supplémentaire que les voyageurs
devraient faire pendant son voyage
bon on pourrait toujours en discuter
mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
crainte que de la réalité puisque ici en
guyane on a instauré ces mesures depuis
plusieurs mois et ces mesures semblent
fonctionner la population actuellement à
1 est un peu réticente à l'idée de se
faire vacciner et le voyais les variants
brésilien qui augmente fait en sorte que
les gens prennent de plus en plus
conscience et nous médecins nous
incitons davantage il ya l'ouverture
d'un vaccinodromes dépit le 30 mars qui
a un lieu où les gens peuvent aller sans
rendez vous donc il ya certaines mesures
incitatives qui feront que je suis
persuadé que les taux des personnes
vaccinées va être plus important
qu'est-ce que quel bilan vous faites
justement de la vaccination jusqu'à
présent en guyane
vous savez la vaccination a eu du mal à
prendre a encore un peu de mal à prendre
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord des
raisons culturelles on est dans une zone
tropicale où les gens ont l'habitude et
s'auto soignés par des plantes par tas
de choses et ya une méfiance je dirais
même une forme de défiance vis-à-vis à
la vaccine à vis de la vaccination
cependant nous au niveau du conseil de
l'ordre au niveau des collègues nous
essayons de jouer de la pédagogie
il y a le vaccin obligatoire de la
fièvre jaune
tout le monde en guyane ou presque est
obligé de se vacciner et les gens se
vaccine sans problème pourquoi il ya
cette méfiance vis-à-vis des vaccins
un contre lacko vide c'est qui c'est un
vaccin qui est un petit peu qui entraîne
qui avec lui certaines constitutions
certaines idées reçues qui ne sont pas
fondées c'est pour ça que nous assistons
sur une forme de pédagogie expliquer
d'une cuite est en tout cas actuellement
trouver des ce vaccin enfin de pouvoir
amener beaucoup de patients à se faire
vacciner et le renfort en provenance le
soutien en provenance de la métropole
quel bilan vous fait à ce niveau en tout
cas c'est trop c'est prématuré de
pouvoir faire un bilan actuellement mais
si on se base sur ce qui s'est passé
lors de la première vague
c'était un accord nécessaire pour
stabiliser cette endémie actuellement
nous c'est un peu prématuré pour prendre
des pour tirer une conclusion on pourra
tirer les conclusions si le voit rien
n'est fait pas trop de dégâts sur notre
territoire
merci beaucoup à vous félix est un
combat rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste merci à vous